across the country
ordinary americans from all walks of
life are taking whatever measures
necessary to prepare i'm preparing my
family for the total destruction of the
power grid the yellowstone super volcano
a financial collapse and protect
themselves when survival is the goal
it's into the spider hole
fast fast fast fast
from what they perceive is the fast
approaching end of the world as we know
it
what i'm gonna use
like this
next we go inside the lives of three
committed preppers you gotta hurry we've
devised extensive plans
let's grab these water tanks and food
gone to great lengths which one of you
would like to be in the radiation seat
i'm gonna pass out bradford and made
huge personal sacrifices to ensure their
very survival in my mind i think the
world's kind of falling apart and it's
only gonna get worse come on let's go
the experts will assess their extreme
preps and decide if they have what it
takes to face armageddon all right let's
do this and to survive i get out of my
way i'm bigger than you good night
everyone
this is doomsday preppers
[Music]
for over half a century retired
scientist bruce beech has been certain
that the world will end
this is going to be a universal
catastrophe
he's gone he said i don't think there's
going to be a two-minute warning
there's this great possibility
mankind can destroy itself
i think the nuclear war is inevitable
in a catastrophe of this size 80 percent
of the population will die during the
first two years
the things that will kill them are
social disruption plagues
lack of food lack of heat exposure
it's a random sort of thing it's who's
going to be saved and who isn't
to save mankind from apocalyptic
destruction bruce has taken it upon
himself to build a haven for humanity
a unique place to sit out the end of the
world
this is a 10 000 square foot shelter for
a nuclear war
he built this nuclear shelter in 1985
as an underground orphanage a place
where a new generation could be saved
from nuclear apocalypse
save the children that's
a basic human characteristic
there are hope for the continuation of
life and for
building the new and better world
bruce's protected safe house is
constructed from building blocks that
many kids would consider familiar
surroundings
42 recycled school buses linked together
and buried under 18 inches of concrete
and 14 feet of earth school buses were
built to a particular government
standard of very strong rigid steel
over the roofs school buses can support
one and a half times their weight
without incurring damage and cost as
little as 300 second hand making them a
prepper favorite for bug out vehicles
and even safe mobile homes we can have
500 people in here but we have to have a
number of people also to watch after the
children
that's our number one mission it has
been estimated that if a global nuclear
war occurred up to a billion lives would
be at risk in the months and years
following bruce sees this shelter as a
safe house where at least some could
survive he named it the successor to
noah's ark arc two last time water next
time the fire
there are twenty thousand these weapons
in the world there's never a time in
man's history and he's developed the
weapon that he hasn't used it
and it's just
things are becoming more and more
critical
because dangerous radiation can travel
hundreds of miles from the source of a
nuclear detonation bruce is worried that
an attack on american missile bases in
the central us could send radioactive
fallout rocketing towards canada
if there were a big nuclear war and a
lot of bombing out there north and south
dakota that fallout goes up in the air
and the jet stream grabs it if you study
the maps for this the predominant place
that falls out is right here in southern
ontario we're in the hottest spot the
whole of north america for the amount of
fallout that anybody gets
bruce and his wife gene have been
prepping this apocalyptic shelter for
over 30 years
but as they get older the wider beach
clan regularly pitch in to keep it
afloat my granddaughter and my grandson
have done lots of work on this shelter
we built the shed we definitely do help
clean and remove things from boxes into
tupperware containers and make sure
everything's sanitary
i hope some plumbing some electricity
work so people can live down there when
it's the right time go in there
okay there we are there we go bruce is
in the process of teaching his grandkids
evan and shayna the way of the ark and
today he is going over the admissions
process we have these gates that we
close
if we aren't taking anyone in
then we have the heavy door okay kiddos
this is the way people come in to the
shelter i'm going to explain what we do
for admission process for them here
so that you'll be able to explain this
to other people and
help with it when the time comes
if a nuclear blast is reported the beech
family will head to the ark and start
taking in young refugees we're going to
say to people well we have room for your
children but we don't have room for you
that's the nature of life
this is the lifeboat
first thing that we do with people when
we bring them in
is we have to decontaminate them
if they
have any measurable radiation that means
they have to be stripped
get in the shower washed off
even a simple shower can remove many
harmful radioactive materials from the
skin so experts recommend that you wash
yourself and remove contaminated
clothing as soon as you are exposed to
radiation
which one of you'd like to be in
radiation see i will
you will
okay
you want to be a radiation suit too sure
once clean each of the ark's inhabitants
will wear sterilized protective suits
there
suit
too tall for this
on addition on your back we have
stencils to stencil your name because
looking at anybody from the back you
can't tell who they are they all look
the same unless we have these
names on it and bruce even has a plan
for those he cannot take into the ark
okay you're doing good work troops keep
it up
this weekend shayna and her mom bahia
are cleaning and putting together go
away kits packs that will help people
live outside of the ark
so we're sending them away with these
radiation detectors because we don't
have any more capacity in the shelter
the different ones have different
strengths i think because you cannot see
smell or feel nuclear radiation
detectors like these dissimitars are
often an essential part of prepper's
survival kits
they will allow people outside the ark
to avoid areas of intense fallout and
treat or isolate people already affected
by radiation
we're getting cleaned up
i'm going to trap myself in here one day
and i'll never be able to get
all
out
lots of people
don't understand grandpa at all so they
think he's pretty eccentric people are
always asking me questions what's the
bomb shelter like and i'm sure you get
asked questions like that too when you
talk to your friends
you know in high school it's hard doing
you know your family's a little
different than everybody else's so you
have to know that you're here to help
them and
that you love them no matter what this
weekend we probably cleaned out 30 huge
boxes of these disseminates ready to go
this is a major part of our life just as
much as his grandpa's
it's his dream and his goal so it
one day it will be our dream and our
goal to uh finish what he has started
all still
stand up here for a minute
beyond his family bruce wants his local
community to know that they have
somewhere safe to go during a nuclear
war
so today he is showing local school kids
around the arc okay come on down guys
this is like an underground submarine
we're trying to get younger people
involved the more people that you have
in your community the more resources
that you have all right
this way
once inside the shelter the 500 young
refugees will sleep in one of the five
school buses dedicated to bunk beds
this bunk room is for 96 children and we
put two small children under the age of
five foot the foot in each of the bunks
we sleep the children 12 hours a day and
two shifts 48.
bruce's rotating sleep system is similar
to that used on real submarines and
allows him to house not just 250 but 500
people in the ark all the bunk rooms are
very much like this
bruce expects that his refugees will
have to stay inside the ark for weeks
maybe months to avoid the worst of the
radiation outside
and while they are underground bruce
will have to feed hundreds of hungry
mouths so he has spent 30 years
stockpiling literally tons of food
and you should take a peek down our pot
our cook says with this pot and his oven
in the next one that he can give a roll
and a biscuit 3 000 people and a soup to
3 000 people a day i didn't think it
would be this big it's like extensive
it's huge it's pretty
mind-blowing to think that it can fit so
many people underground and that's just
unreal
all righty coming this way you all want
to be in here
one of the hazards of living underground
for an extended period is making sure
you have enough air to breathe
at full capacity and without proper air
circulation bruce's 10 000 foot shelter
would run out of oxygen in approximately
half a day
okay
one of the important things about
problems in the shelter one things we
have to concerned about
is being able to move air anywhere we
want to so bruce has devised a rather
unusual and cost-effective air
circulation system this is one of the
systems we've designed
i thought it was going to go down the
hallway i could have redirected it this
strong line of garbage bags can
distribute 300 cubic feet of air from
the outside vents to different locations
in the shelter my wife spent hours and
hours taping
do you ever get tired of waiting for the
world to end many people say look at
that crazy old man how he's wasted his
life out there always worrying about the
world's going to end
when instead he had been out playing
golf
you know
getting that little white ball out there
in the hole and this wouldn't been
meaningful to me
so we're going to open the steel door
here
[Music]
this is the back door to the shelter
many people think that i am obsessive i
guess it depends on what one is obsessed
with they're obsessed with
dedicating their life to humanity and
well that maybe that's a good obsession
bruce's shelter was built as a second
noah's ark a unique haven from a nuclear
apocalypse but it has never officially
been named until now i think it's
awesome
in rural ontario canada a ten thousand
square foot underground shelter named
arc ii sits ready to save hundreds of
children from nuclear armageddon arc 2
is
purpose
is to help those who survive to rebuild
society
we are not about survival
we are about reconstruction bruce beech
and his wife gene have dedicated over 30
years to the maintenance of this unique
space constructed from 42 recycled and
buried school buses gene really did help
me a lot
about the shelter she's made a lot of
sacrifices
she's never bought any new clothes and i
i don't know how many years we don't
take vacations this is our lifestyle
it's been very different for most people
right it has
over the years bruce has created a
network of arc ii preppers based all
around the united states i may not
live through to see it but i've
certainly spread this idea to thousands
and thousands of people already his
latest collaborative project is an
off-grid communication system that can
be used as the ark's lifeline to the
outside world during a nuclear war
tonight he is meeting with greg franklin
and lisa maggiore to go over the details
local communication are going to be a
very very important factor in the
recovery process for security to know
what's happening around you to know
where it's safe to go the secondary
effect of a nuclear detonation is an emp
a wave of electromagnetic energy
powerful enough to bring down the grid
every method of communication that we
have whether it be cell phones or
telephones or internet all rely on
extensive infrastructure which will
almost certainly be destroyed in our
scenario so they are building a ham
radio system widely used by preppers
because it relies only on naturally
existing radio waves to transmit
messages and can work independently from
the electrical grid
well this will be run battery powered
and those will be charged by
solar power lisa's communicating with
toronto right now about 50 miles
distance we're bouncing the signal off
the ionosphere about 400 kilometers
above us
and that signal is returning
directly down even local police services
don't have that capability bruce and
greg plan to distribute these radios to
key members of the local community so in
the event of a nuclear war they can keep
in touch with the outside world about
supplies radiation levels and security
communication is is going to be key to
survival hopefully we'll be able to
start distributing these units in the in
the very near future
and uh certainly hopefully before before
the missiles fly
the name arc 2 was coined decades ago
but the exterior of the shelter gives
away no clues as to what is inside
now that is about to change bruce and
his wife jean have gathered the beach
family together to mark the occasion a
few weeks ago he called me up and just
said uh i know you're a carver and would
you be able to
give me something rustic i remembered
that there was a man who had buried 42
buses and then also no phil came
together it was worth just doing the
sign just so i could talk to him
the ark is about our service to humanity
and whether or not i pass the arkham to
the grandchildren is relevant
what is important
that i pass on to my grandchildren
is a dedication
of service to humanity so that's what
my
life is about what my legacy will be
i have no idea i may be entirely
wrong written off forgotten the world
may never know about me uh 10 20 years
from now you know so the first arc was
for what yeah for water this one's for
fire fire there you go we always see
ourselves coming back here finishing up
what grandpa started and
improving it this project is very
inspirational
just tell us how far a man can go to
follow his dream
i think it's awesome really special
fits perfectly right in there
[Music]
a global arsenal of nearly 20 000
weapons makes the possibility of a
nuclear incident a real tangible threat
however the united states and russia are
moving towards a policy of nuclear
disarmament aimed at reducing the
likelihood of global nuclear war
new father jeremy fears his year old son
will face a future filled with hardship
due to the depletion of oil reserves can
they outrun the desperate hordes in
their retired army truck
jeremy lives outside salt lake city utah
with his wife kelly and their son xander
he's the owner of a digital media
company okay let's roll it i'm kind of a
new dad i've got a one-year-old and he
is so much fun
i love being a father okay okay
but jeremy and kelly aren't thinking of
college when they plan for xander's
future
i'm preparing for the collapse of
society due to peak oil
we gotta hurry three
the term peak oil refers to the eventual
decline in the supply of oil reserves if
oil becomes harder to get the price will
increase past the point when people can
afford to buy it
the u.s alone consumes 20 million
barrels of oil every day and global
demand is projected to grow by a quarter
by 2030. i think drastic changes could
happen
literally in a matter of a couple years
from now all it takes is for the demand
for oil to outstrip the supply and we've
been on the razor's edge of that for a
really long time
my worst case scenario is that oil
exporting countries stop exporting and
gas pumps start running dry around
america
then that just has a cascading effect
across our entire society people won't
be able to go to work and if you can't
go to work then infrastructure starts to
fail
with 86 percent of americans commuting
to work by car jeremy fears society will
grind to a halt once infrastructure
starts to fail we could eventually even
see the grid go down and if the grid
goes down society as we know it will be
very very changed
my first reaction to my husband's desire
to start prepping
was
a little scared i actually walked away
and was like trying to ignore him
because i didn't want to admit it it
took me about a year to
finally come to terms with the idea of
prepping
in my mind i think the world's kind of
falling apart and it's only going to get
worse
i'd like to think of myself actually as
a fairly balanced person and i don't
think this is an obsession it's just a
precaution
after peak oil jeremy believes rolling
blackouts will be common without the
grid basic utilities and services will
cease to function including one of
life's vital conveniences
tap water
so jeremy and kelly have identified
their nearest source of water
their hot tub
when i first told my wife that we might
be drinking water out of the hot tub she
seemed a little bit reluctant but i
think we both decided that we'd be safe
once we'd filtered it
this is our emergency supply we've got
what 400 450 gallons of water balance
ready to go jeremy and kelly are able to
ration their hot tub water by using the
drainage tube
this allows them to preserve a precious
resource i never would have thought that
getting water from the hot tub having
clean water is essential to survival so
in a grid down situation it is
imperative to have a water purification
system the 450 gallons of water in the
hot tub could hydrate jeremy kelly and
xander for about eight months
two are you kidding me
okay i can't believe we're actually
making hot chocolate out
of hot tub water okay
hot tub hot chocolate
nice yum
that's actually not bad it's fine
nice
okay that works even when the grid goes
down and the world is is
going crazy
my home and my family are the most
important thing to me and keeping
that part of our life as normal as
possible is very important to me
even though he's purifying water for his
family jeremy is still concerned about
infections and disease one of the
concerns in the post-collapse world is
the lack of
access to medical
facilities antibiotics things like that
eighty percent of the active ingredients
used in american drugs are made overseas
and without the fuel to ship them
emergency treatment would be in short
supply so jeremy is leaving nothing to
chance
turns out that the antibiotics used for
fish tanks is exactly the same
antibiotics as
are prescribed for humans so you can
actually get human antibiotics at a pet
store common antibiotics like
amoxicillin are marketed under different
names for aquatic use fish antibiotics
are a favorite among preppers to
stockpile because they are widely
available without a prescription or
pharmacist
part of being a prepper is being
prepared for anything and that includes
getting sick and
if there's no doctor available to give
you a prescription or simply run out of
antibiotics you've got to have them
stockpiled
antibiotics and hot tub hot chocolate
won't save jeremy and his family if
their community falls prey to violence
so jeremy has a serious backup plan
i just call it the beast most of the
time
experts disagree about when we will
reach the peak of oil production
some estimate it will peak as soon as
2035.
jeremy believes it already has i
personally believe that actually peak
oil has happened i think we saw that
from the 2008 financial collapse it was
actually a result of an energy shock
from 2007 or so and i think in the
future we'll see more of those and
they're going to be even faster and
more striking
jeremy and his wife kelly believe
nowhere not even their home will be safe
after the peak oil crash
if society really does collapse to the
point where your neighbors become
desperate or people are raiding your
neighborhood for your supplies it might
become necessary to bug out jeremy
believes a peak oil crisis will lead to
social collapse a situation that has led
to torture cannibalism and mass
executions around the world
jeremy and kelly are prepared to leave
everything behind to protect their son
and jeremy has found ironic means to
that end
he calls it the beast
[Music]
jeremy found the beast online and
purchased it used from a prop company
for 3 500
when my husband jeremy came to me for
the first time and told me he wanted to
buy an army truck i honestly thought he
was nuts
why in the world do we need an army
truck where are we going to park an army
truck we live in the suburbs i thought
he was he was insane
and before it was a civilian vehicle the
beast served in desert storm so
this truck is an actual military vehicle
it's called the m35 or affectionately
known as the deuce and a half the m35 is
a favored transport vehicle of the us
army it can carry five thousand pounds
of cargo off-road and up to ten thousand
pounds on road
if kelly and jeremy decide to bug out
the beasts will offer them
transportation a means to carry supplies
and even shelter and so when we started
talking about that i started realizing
you know what this is a fabulous idea
it's shelter it's also
transportation it's got a huge
compartment we can put all of our water
we can put all of our food we can put
the bunk bed in there
have a place to sleep and
really shelter our family in so if we do
need to get out of town we do need to
leave our home and flee we have a
vehicle to do so in
but if jeremy and kelly take to the road
they're going to need fuel to power a
mobile lifestyle and while it might look
like a gas guzzler the beast is actually
quite flexible when it comes to fuel
this truck is a multi-fuel vehicle and
so if we do have peak oil and certain
kinds of fuel become really really hard
to come by this will literally run on
just about any liquid fuel it'll run on
diesel which it prefers you can put gas
in it kerosene jet fuel doesn't like the
octane but it'll work but most
importantly to me yeah it actually can
run and use motor oil motor oil is used
to lubricate an internal combustion
engine's moving parts
most people recognize motor oil as the
stuff their mechanic changes out every
three thousand miles
but one man's trash is another man's
treasure
in a doomsday scenario this truck you
know it'll get us anywhere
and they get us there using a fuel that
pretty much
nobody else needs with roughly 250
million passenger cars in america jeremy
will be able to siphon fuel from a
virtually unlimited supply after a peak
oil doomsday but for safety he wants to
make sure he can at least get his family
out of harm's way we're hoping to
stockpile around a thousand to 1500
gallons of used motor oil for us to use
in the case of an emergency
that is one battle truck
today jeremy and his friend grayden
visit a local service station it's just
the place to find large quantities of
used motor oil awaiting disposal
gary yes jeremy jeremy i told earlier
about getting some of your used motor
oil oh yeah that's awesome yeah yeah
what do you use it for see that big army
truck house when you pull in yeah um it
runs i use more oil if it works good i
might looking to do something like that
too because i got lots of used motor
oils that's very difficult welcome to it
the first time i saw that big truck i
thought it was being invaded i didn't
know what it was
it's pretty big
i feel like a fireman
siphoning used motor oil is a messy job
requiring special tools and elbow grease
get this thing on here
jeremy has three liquid storage tanks
one on board and two more in a secure
location for stockpiling used motor oil
okay go get her fired up sweet
each can hold up to 400 gallons
looks good and looks like we got about i
think we got about 300 gallons out of
these guys jeremy and graydon filter the
oil through a sock to catch any debris
like dirt metal scrapings and other fine
particles that may be left behind from
prior use
with their new motor oil stores jeremy
and kelly believe they now have enough
oil to drive halfway across the
country so they are putting themselves
to the test
hey jerry we gotta hurry we gotta hurry
let's grab these water tanks
and food oh these are heavy
what else swim bag grab the tent grab
the rope hurry i got the solar oven
gun gun you got the gun i got the gun
i'll get the baby okay
[Music]
but if they go mobile jeremy can't do
all the driving himself
he needs a competent co-pilot you want
to learn to drive this thing i sure do i
think it'd be fun it's an army truck
from the 70s it doesn't have power
steering it doesn't have all the smooth
transmission shifting gears that our
average vehicles do mommy's gonna drive
how scary is that huh
all right let's do this
that's great it starts with it's not
your traditional gear shifting now we're
gonna you're gonna go to a second pretty
quick so get moving check your mirror
that's first go to second
that's reversed
this is hard yeah let's go do some
donuts out here in this dirt field
here we go we're going off-road yeah
baby
sanders sleeping through it all back
punch it punch it punch it get it plenty
of momentum
and
punch it oh
yeah sorry buddy does everybody just go
manhattan
or a woman handle it like aggressive
with her
that was awesome
sorry buddy
as long as i've got my son on my lap and
my husband in the driver's seat that's
all i need
jeremy the experts practical preppers
commend you for taking the first steps
in being prepared
the beast is impressive and alternate
fuel sources will be a great asset the
truck will also be able to push stalled
vehicles out of the way
we suggest investing in a centrifuge
this would clean used oil faster i
looked a little bit into centrifugal
systems but
um didn't know a lot about it so
something i'll definitely look into
you should have bug out bags packed and
ready to grab the truck should be
stocked and awaiting departure at all
times
i agree we're actually putting some
items in the truck but um individual bug
out bags is
always been on our plans and just
something we haven't gotten around to
and i do think it should be a priority
since national geographic was here we've
done our best to take the experts advice
specifically we've actually finally got
our bug out bags and our get home bags
ready to go
and we have also loaded up our truck
with more provisions and supplies so in
the event we needed to just jump in our
truck and go we'd be able to do so
while some experts believe peak oil has
already occurred others believe it is
decades away there are so many variables
that creating an accurate projection is
difficult
but the u.s strategic petroleum reserve
which houses the largest stockpile of
government-owned crude oil in the world
would last only 38 days
bradford frank is a psychiatrist who
believes a killer flu pandemic will hit
america but his wife and daughter have
their doubts you almost run out of money
and you almost run out of me
will dr frank's doomsday prescription be
enough to satisfy his family and the
experts
[Music]
bradford frank is a psychiatrist who
lives in sunny san diego california
that's very risky like a consummate
professional he cares deeply about the
well-being of his patients
but he's also concerned
about the end of the world
i'm preparing for a worldwide pandemic
that will end life as we know it
awesome
[Music]
sometimes people refer to me as dr doom
i think that most people would look at
me and say he's a nutcase
he's a psychiatrist he's obviously crazy
and that's the reason that i don't talk
to a lot of people about prepping
i went to yale and studied infectious
diseases and that's where i started to
get interested in influenza and in
particular bird flu
bradford is prepping for an avian flu
that would wipe out millions of
americans
super influenza the superbug
is not
a completely new event
he believes a new extremely contagious
form of bird flu will transmit to humans
then spread through the population like
wildfire
in the united states grave sites
couldn't be dug fast enough bodies
stacked in the streets like cordwood
the world health organization considers
100 million infections a conservative
estimate for a global pandemic
people would become hysterical there
would be chaos throughout the world
it's not a question if it's going to
occur again it's only a question of when
you really want to go
bradford wants to get his whole family
involved in prepping
i wanted to just kind of go over a
couple things in case i'm not at home
when when there's a problem
and so he has asked his wife naren to
help him inventory his medical supplies
i am able to obtain antibiotics and
other medications because i am a
physician i actually buy these in large
quantities so we have all these
medicines
it's a little bit hard to know what to
do with the antibiotics if you're not a
doctor
after a pandemic bradford believes that
hospitals will become hot zones for
infection so he is stockpiling
antibiotics to ensure his family never
needs to leave the house for medical
care
okay so yeah this one this one is still
good
uh let's see these are the medicines
that i got for the bird flu this expired
in 2006
that's not good i don't want you to
spend so much money on that i did these
were very expensive medicines that's
money money bradford has spent about
fifteen thousand dollars on prepping to
date and his wife thinks he's making a
bad investment
i told him do you like to think all
negative things and scary things and
nothing's going to happen in the global
pandemic bradford fears the lethal virus
would be passed from person to person
through the air
if it was a particularly virulent strain
standing even six feet from a contagious
person could be deadly
gotta get these masks on these n95 masks
on today he has asked naren and his
daughter alexandra to practice wearing
n95 surgical masks
these masks help filter out 95 percent
of air particles including ones that
would carry the virus
and bradford has stored 400 of them are
you good you're on
take some breaths we run drills like
this because it's very important that
the family understands what to do in an
emergency
the way you get the virus is by human
interaction it's transmitted through the
air i'm gonna pass out bradford no you
it just feels that way he's my husband
he he have his opinion and i have my
opinion it's okay if we compromise it's
okay that's what the marriage all about
but
my husband brad is not compromised
despite naren's objections bradford has
stockpiled hundreds of food cans and one
thousand pounds of rice
it looks like any house but behind these
closed doors there are all these
preparations alexandra can you come here
and help me honey alexandra is charged
with helping them preserve their
supplies
bradford considers rice the perfect
prepper food because it's inexpensive
contains protein and has a long shelf
life can you give me a bucket so the way
that i store the rice is to put it into
a food grade bucket within that bucket i
put a mylar bag that's also designed for
food
he then adds one extra step that will
ensure his rice lasts for up to 10 years
okay here we go i have a special
technique where i i've purchased a small
nitrogen tank the nitrogen goes into the
bucket nitrogen is heavier than oxygen
you hear it yeah i hear it can feel it
too with the nitrogen pushing the oxygen
out this should flame should go out
because there's no oxygen oxygen burns
nitrogen doesn't burn see
using this method bradford makes sure
his rice is sealed off without exposure
to oxygen which is the key to keeping it
fresh long term why do we need the rice
to last so long uh i don't need it
because i probably won't be here but you
might need it
just in case there's a terrible
catastrophe
and chaos in society and there's no food
we don't have any food
i don't really know how i feel about my
dad being so concerned about bird flu he
lets it go to his head
too much sometimes and i feel like he
could be a little neurotic but
it's good that we have a little back-up
plan
my daughter
thinks that i am quote paranoid i say
yes i think i am paranoid but what i
would refer to as practical paranoia
bradford has stored enough food to last
his family for a year
after a pandemic he believes public
places like supermarkets will become
hotbeds of deadly infection so they'll
need to live off their stockpiles
i don't believe in have all this food
i don't want to have all this food
when you want to survive you'll find
anything to survive like the rabbit
outside the back and the snake and the
crickets i eat anything i can find naren
does not see the wisdom in prepping for
a future pandemic
even though she knows more about
survival than just about anybody my
beautiful wife is cambodian and was
involved in the
khmer rouge war in cambodia where
her primary relatives were all killed
naren was 19 when she escaped from a
prison camp in cambodia during the khmer
rouge genocide that killed two million
people
it's 1977 when they start killing
i start to
run
you run
steal food or whatever you have to do to
survive
i'm the only one to survive in my family
i don't need a lot of food and i don't
need a lot of medicine
i know how to survive in a different way
but is it possible that bradford is
taking his prepping too far
[Applause]
wow and what will his family think when
he shows them their bug out location for
the first time you know it's a place
that we can come to
come on it's an emergency san diego
psychiatrist bradford frank has spent 10
years and thousands of dollars prepping
to survive an avian flu pandemic that
will kill millions his wife and daughter
think it's all a waste well you almost
run out of money and you almost run out
of me
bradford is determined to keep his
family safe even if they don't
appreciate his efforts
if a deadly pandemic sweeps through san
diego he fears infected people will
target doctors houses in search of
medicine
so he's stepping up his security
preparations we're gonna set it up on
the end he's replacing his sliding doors
with a quarter inch thick sheet of
ballistic glass designed to withstand a
point-blank shot from a nine-millimeter
and whatever else a potential invader
might throw at it
okay we're all finished
here okay let's uh
look at this
it's supposed to withstand anything
okay try that one
go
oh
wow
[Music]
oh awesome nothing is getting through
that window
if a flu pandemic hits bradford fears
that the deadly virus could spread
quickly between neighbors so the final
part of his plan is to secure an
isolated bug-out location as far away
from other people as possible today he's
taking his family there for the first
time there could be so many people
trying to believe that the roads will
get packed up so we have to
we have to be one of the first people to
leave how can be the first people to
leave you have about a million food is
in there no we're not going to take
everything we're just going to take what
we here we go again
come on girls
come on let's go
the number one protection in a global
pandemic
is being away from other people who may
be infectious
okay it's getting dark so let's get
going everybody get a helmet
this is ridiculous
it's ridiculous yes
we're having fun though aren't we no
if bradford needs to quarantine his
family from a deadly airborne virus he
believes this spot a gem mine located
2.5 hours from san diego may be ideal
it's far enough away from a population
center to keep his family away from
contagious people and close enough to
reach quickly if a pandemic breaks out
okay now this is just like a ladder and
we're just going to go in kind of
crawling down the ladder pick up us
alexander you follow me honey yes if you
have to live with your father he's
serious just do it to get into the cave
the frank family must climb down 80 feet
believes the isolated location of this
cave further safeguards his family from
possible infection
i have just a very powerful
survival instinct
that would propel me
to continue to scratch
and claw
my way forward and see honey you know
you say i never take you places and look
at this this is fabulous
so this is our home away from
home at the end of the world what do you
think
when he said looking for a cave it feel
like i go through war again
so why we have to go to the cave
so bring back old memory and bring food
and fear can be starving again scary
again i'm gonna die
while escaping the khmer rouge naren
survived by hiding in a cave for two
months
and you can't burn firewood people find
out
you can't have any light any fire any
anything so you can't cook
and you have to sleep next to each other
because very cold sometimes
no no aids no fire no noise
maybe that's why i don't want to be down
here in a cave before i came here today
i wasn't really too aware that my wife
had spent some time in a cave i think
she probably told me that years ago but
it's not something that we talk about
very often because it's it's so painful
for her to discuss
i'm not sure if this cave is going to
really work out for my new doomsday home
given the fact that my wife is so
opposed to it
bradford the experts practical preppers
think your medical background will make
you extremely valuable in times of chaos
and civil unrest
yeah i think i think so
however if you ultimately choose to bug
out to an isolated location we do not
suggest a cave a cave is susceptible to
moisture which will destroy your food
stores
it's certainly not the perfect solution
and
you know we'll consider
possibly a stronger shelter there
are advantages and disadvantages with
everything that's for sure
since national geographic was here
several months ago i was carjacked at
gunpoint while on vacation
things turned out well and the
perpetrators are behind bars but i
actually hope that this experience is a
positive one for my my for my family in
helping them to understand that bad
things can happen even when you least
expect them
while avian bird flu spreads relatively
freely in wild and domestic bird species
it does not normally affect human beings
cases of interspecies transmission from
bird to human are sporadic at best and
while an influenza pandemic is likely to
occur in the future it is unclear when
and how severe such an event would be
[Music]
you